bold
plans joe biden says china's goal to own
america before 2035 vt post story
president biden during the speech to
american service members in virginia
said chinese leadership thinks it will
own america before 2035. we're in a
battle between
democracies and auto uh uh uh uh
uh okay you see the current hypocrisy
biden told troops at joint base
langley eustis in hampton the more
complicated the world becomes the more
difficult it is for democracies to come
together and reach consensus
i've spent more time with president xi
of china than any other world dealer
leader has for 24 hours of private
meetings with him
just uh with just an interpreter 17 000
miles traveling with him in china and
here
he firmly believes that china before the
year 2035 is going to own america
because
autocracies can make quick decisions
biden said the us's political landscape
has never been more divided and that
appears to be among the reasons biden
believes china could think
it has an ownership opening got a real
problem with this
um and he also brags about the fact that
no
leader from america spent more time with
the chinese president that they traveled
together for 17 000 miles with
and then they were together for 24 hours
with just an interpreter and they're
discussing these things
why are you telling us this in the
fashion that you are why aren't you more
like um
china thinks they're going to own us but
i'm telling you right now i will not let
that happen
it's not going to happen on my watch i
didn't get that from him saying this
um i would just china is clearly
has a strategy to do this part of the
problem that there's this division that
he talks about
is because of biden and i would just
like to hear something from him
saying yeah we know what you're up to
and we've got a counter plan to make
sure that doesn't happen
like he just made it seem like fact as
opposed to this is a huge problem
if china thinks they're going to own us
and we're not going to allow it to
happen how come this isn't a huge
like issue for him a little too cavalier
for me
i i think it is i think you're just
reading the the headline and
and just making an assumption he's
basically saying we need to do something
about china i think the biggest fear
when biden came into office was people
saying well he's not going to be tough
on china and
that was all trump biden is basically
saying look i'm going to pick up where
trump left off okay
he's been like what's my favorite show
that i watch every sunday it's fareed
zakaria
and he's a very smart guy and he
basically said in a world where
americans
are so divided the one issue that we all
agree on is the threat that china is
imposing
okay and he went off for five minutes on
the threat that china's imposing and
this guy is a
liberal uh very smart guy on cnn and
just went off
on the fears of china so it's very easy
to say well the right
uh is doing everything against china and
the left isn't that's just not true
okay plus look at what's going on in the
world you said the biggest
threat to china potentially if the world
coalesces and actually fights china
so you have india you have australia you
have japan you have
all the countries in the south china sea
that are basically saying oh the eu
keep in mind enough's enough uh let's
get to the bottom what the hell china's
up to
so i think in theory uh
saying that biden isn't doing enough or
the world isn't doing enough is great to
say it's great for headlines but i think
in actuality
people understand that china is a major
threat yeah i don't i don't know if i
buy that
and and here's here's how i see that um
is it fair to say that hunter has had
some dealings with china yes
yes it's public right now he writes
about it people talk about it it's
public it's nothing that anybody is
fighting that there's not
uh any issues there is it fair to say
that
hunter had some bad uh habits
and addictions yes that maybe when
you're
addicted to a drug you tend to make
stupid decisions is that a fair
assessment when you're on crack read his
book
right you make bad decisions he talks
about it openly do you agree with that
when you're on drugs you make bad
decisions yeah but
okay where are you going i'm gonna go
stay with me here is it fair to say that
if you're dealing with
folks in china and you like drugs and
the enemy knows
what you like they know how to persuade
you and then they know how to get
information from you
which means in a situation like this do
you think china has intel on hunter that
we don't know about
do you i don't know i think for me if
i'm a betting man i'm going to say 10
the answer is yes i think china has some
stuff on hunter
which means any conversation they have
with joe it's going to be based around
hunter the whole story with j edgar
hoover when the mob
went with them and they said hey just so
you know the next time you act tough
here's what we have of you
i have a feeling there was a moment
where she said let's walk out over here
and i want to talk to you by ourselves
here's what we have moving forward
here's what your script is this is what
you can say
and here's what you can't say and if you
don't it's not going to be nice for you
i just want you to know this if he
didn't say it somebody may have told him
that
maybe completely wrong i may be
completely over speculating that's why i
said 10
credence i'm giving to this so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye